you've written a blog post on what
you've been up to uh you wrote this in
October 2022 I quote mostly I try to
learn a lot
for example the political events of 2014
to 2016 made clear to me that I didn't
understand politics at all referencing
maybe some of this this book here
um so I deliberately withdrew from
political engagement and fundraising and
instead read my way back into history
and as far to the political left and
political right as I could so just high
level question what's your approach to
learning
so it's basically I would say it's it's
an autodive act um uh so it's sort of
goes it's going down the rabbit holes so
it's a combination let's say I kind of
allude to it in that quote It's a
combination of breadth and depth
um and so I tend to yeah I tend to I go
abroad by the nature of what I do I go
broad but then I tend to go deep in a
rabbit hole for a while read everything
I can and then come out of it and I
might not revisit that rabbit hole for
you know another decade and in that blog
post that I'd recommend people go check
out you actually list a bunch of
different books that you recommend on
different topics on the American left
and the American right
uh it's just a lot of really good stuff
the best explanation for the current
structure of our society and politics
you give to recommendations four books
on the Spanish Civil War six books on
deep history of the American right
comprehensive biocracy disease of Adolf
Hitler of one of which I read can
recommend uh six books in the Deep
history of the American left so American
right American left looking at the
history to give you the context
um biography of uh Vladimir Lenin two of
them on the French Revolution actually I
have never read the biography on Lennon
maybe that that would be useful
everything's been so Mark's focused the
Sebastian biography of London is
extraordinary uh Victor Sebastian okay
blow your mind yeah so it's still useful
to me incredible yeah it's incredible I
actually think it's the single best book
on the Soviet Union so that the
perspective of Lenin it might be the
best way to look at the Soviet Union
versus Stalin versus Marx versus
very interesting so two books on Fascism
and anti-fascism uh by the same uh
author uh Paul Gottfried uh brilliant
book on the nature of mass movements and
Collective psychology the definitive
work on intellectual life under the
totalitarianism the captive mind uh the
definitive worked on the Practical life
under total terrorism uh there's a bunch
there's a bunch and the single best book
first of all the list here is just
incredible but you say the single best
book I have found on who we are and how
we got here is the ancient city uh by
Numa Dennis festel di kulangus I like it
uh what's uh what did you learn about
who we are as a human civilization from
that book yeah so this is a fascinating
book this one's free but it's free by
the way it's it's in it's a book in the
1860s you can download it or you can buy
pronounce prints of it but um it's uh it
was this guy who was a professor at the
sorbond in the 1860s and he was
apparently a savant on uh Antiquity on
Greek and Roman Antiquity um and the
reason I say that is because his sources
are 100 original Greek and Roman sources
so he wrote a basically a history of
Western Civilization from on the order
of four thousand years ago to basically
the present times entirely working on
Fresh original Greek and Roman Roman
sources
um and what he was specifically trying
to do was he was trying to reconstruct
from the stories of the grace and the
Romans he was trying to reconstruct what
life in the west was like before the
Greeks and the Romans which was in this
in this in the civilization known as the
the indo-europeans
um and the short answer is and this is
sort of Circa 4 000 you know 2000 BC to
you know sort of 500 BC kind of that
1500 year stretch where civilization
developed uh and his conclusion was
basically Cults
um they were basically Cults and the
civilization was organized into Cults
and the the intensity of the Cults was
like a million fold beyond anything that
we would recognize today like it was a
level of
um all encompassing belief and uh an
action around religion
um that was at a level of extremeness
that we wouldn't even recognize it
um uh and and so specifically he tells
the story of basically there were three
levels of Cults there was the family
cult the tribal cult and then the city
cult as as Society scaled up and then
each call was a joint Cult of family
Gods which were ancestor gods and then
nature gods
um and then you're bonding into a family
A Tribe or a city was based on your
adherence to that religion
um people uh who were not of your family
tribe City worshiped different gods
which gave you not just the right with
the responsibility to kill them on site
laughs
right so they were serious about their
Cults hardcore by the way shocking
development I did not realize the zero
concept of individual rights like even
even up through the Greeks and even in
the Romans they didn't have the concept
of individual rights like the idea that
as an individual you have like some
right it's just like nope right and you
look back and you're just like wow
that's just like crazy like fascist and
a degree that we wouldn't recognize
today but it's like well they were
living under extreme pressure for
survival and you and you know the theory
goes you could not have people running
around making claims individual rights
when you're just trying to get like your
tribe through the winter right like you
need like hardcore command and control
and so and and actually if through
Modern political lens those Cults were
basically both fascist and communist
um they were fascist in terms of social
control and then they were Communists in
terms of economics
but you think that's fundamentally that
like pull towards uh Cults is within us
well so so my conclusion from this book
so so so so so the way we naturally
think about the world we live in today
is like we basically have such an
improved version of everything that came
before us right like we we have
basically we've figured out all these
things around morality and ethics and
democracy and all these things and like
they were basically stupid and
retrograde and were like smart
sophisticated and we've improved all
this um I I after reading that book uh I
I now believe in many ways the opposite
which is no actually we are still
running in that original model we're
just running in an incredibly diluted
version of it so we're still running
basically in Cults it's just our Cults
are at like a thousandth or a millionth
the level of intensity right and so our
so just to take religions you know the
modern experience of a Christian in our
time even somebody who considers some a
devout Christian is just a shadow of the
level of intensity of somebody who
belong to a religion back in that period
and then by the way we have constr goes
back to our AI discussion we we we then
sort of endlessly create new calls like
we're trying to fill the void right and
the void is a void of bonding okay
living in their era like everybody
living today transporting that era would
view it as just like completely
intolerable in terms of like the loss of
freedom in the level basically fascist a
control however every single person in
that era and he really stresses this
they knew exactly where they stood they
knew exactly where they belonged they
knew exactly what their purpose was they
know exactly what they needed to do
every day they knew exactly why they
were doing it they had total certainty
about their place in the universe so the
question of meaning the question of
purpose was very distinctly clearly
defined for them absolutely
overwhelmingly
undisputably undeniably as we turn the
volume down on the cultism yes we start
to uh the search for meaning starts
getting harder and harder yes because we
don't have that we're we're ungrounded
we are we're uncentered and we all feel
it right and that's why we reach for you
know it's why we still reach for
religion it's why we reach for you know
people start to take on you know let's
say you know a faith in science maybe
Beyond where they should put it uh you
know by the way like sports teams are
like a you know they're like a tiny
little version of a cult and you know
the you know Apple Keynotes are a tiny
little version of a cult right you know
political you know yeah and there's
called you know there's the political
Spectrum right now right um you know
operating in plain but still not
full-blown compared as to what it was
compared to what it used I mean we would
today consider full-blown but like yes
they're they're at like I don't know a
hundred thousandth or something of the
intensity of what people had back then
so so we live in a world today that in
many ways is more advanced and moral and
so forth and it's certainly a lot nicer
much nicer world to live in but we live
in a world that's like a very washed out
it's like everything has become very
colorless and gray as compared to how
people used to experience things which
is I think why we're so prone to reach
for drama because we there's something
in US deeply evolved where we want that
back
and I wonder where it's all headed as we
turn the volume down more and more